is brother footy troop
mocking the dean is he mocking the salah
is he crossing lines
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
from today better care to your brothers
and sisters and dear friends hope you
guys are aware inshallah before us i
want to praise allah the most merciful
the most trust or praise his glory and
gratitude belong to him
brother susie may allah bless him
inshallah so far he's been getting
closer to the dean of the trip that he
went with brother adam
and brother slim recently he gifted his
mom with something that is priceless he
used to
shower with lots of gifts but that meant
nothing to his mom because she wanted
something that is
more theater more closer to her which is
to go um with her son
and fujitube gifted her with that may
allah bless him
one of the blessings if you want
promises is if you want blessings in
your life
be obedient to your parents their
dwarves will open
doors that nothing can bring sisters and
we know there are specific situations
where parents oppressed children we're
not talking about that
however oh good and positive may allah
bless them and go alright i hope it will
be a
life-changing experience for you but
this video
left some people with raised eyebrows
question marks
is brother footy troop mocking the dean
is he mocking the salah
is he crossing lines has he let us down
let's watch and see bom says in this
video we're going to see brother
photoshoot on his instagram
showing us something in salah and
something that happens to
most of us let's watch and see and let's
see what lessons we can
learn from this allah
[Music]
he was so close we're just like 30
seconds you couldn't hold it in
wait does that mean we have to do it
again too i don't know
okay guys so now you've seen it now what
he's telling us and showing this is a
reality that happens
now the reason i'm doing this video is
because of this now i know you know guys
a lot of you guys are watching this
thing and i'm gonna have a go out for
the tube i haven't got
no i'll be having to go at you guys why
when a new river comes to islam the
prayer of the salah might be
hard on them so some love scholars say
that allow them to take time and imagine
how important salah
is we have to be leaning with them
because it's a new way even for those
who are coming back to the team
you have to be patient allah says in the
quran to prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi
if you was harsh with them they would
have run away from you
he's saying this to the prophet so much
so that in surah abbas
allah subhanahu wa sent down revelation
again
to the prophet 27 why because the
prophet was too busy giving tawa to the
quraysh
in in the hope to bring them to islam
and a blind man
came to the prophet and all the prophet
did was
just did this facial expression
something along those lines
allah rebuked the prophet peace be upon
him and advised him
that it is not fitting for you to do
that the blind man can't even see the
prophet's reaction
that's not the point the point is that
the prophet peace be upon him should
have not done that because he was
someone genuinely
coming he was interested in islam and
was too occupied the prophet peace be
upon him was okay with the question out
of his
love for them to to bring them to the
heart brothers and sisters
we have to be lenient with people we
can't just start attacking people oh
you're mocking the deal oh you're doing
this this is nonsense
you guys are toxic people who are
attacking fuzzy for no
reason the guy is on a journey let
him take that journey gradually how many
of you guys were lost
how many i was lost i came to islam
eight years ago
i lived a filthy disgusting life i was
lost by the mercy of allah i found the
deen
how is it that you forget this how many
of you guys are practicing
and thinking this arrogant attitude and
looking down at people
this is not the dean islam doesn't teach
you the moment you realize to yourself
that you didn't guide yourself that
allah did you you should be humble and
never
think to yourself oh i'm better than him
oh i'll have a go at him
he's having a gradual process and he's
doing good may allah bless him and keep
him firm
so i'm going to come to his defense
because it really annoys me and i've
consulted with my teachers as well
yes he's just showing a reality yes you
sometimes fart in salah
and we're going to learn lessons from
this as well because the guys two guys
in the back were saying what
oh does that mean that we have to repeat
no you don't because there's evidence
from the hadith of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam i think it's
in bukhari muslim
that once the prophet sallallahu sallam
was leading salah and then he realized
that he was in janaba
so like a major impurification so he had
to what did he do
he notified the companions to stay where
you are
he went and had a shower went got ready
and came back
as soon as possible to finish the salah
off yeah
and even when um
when that filthy scum stabbed him
stabbed him stabbed he got stabbed
bleeding out he got uh been elf
yeah because some believe that you know
bleeding excess bleeding can
you know um cause you to repeat your
salah will do
um etc so guys in the back
as far as i know i've consulted my
teachers that you do not have to repeat
your
salah and this is a whole act i'm just
saying for anybody that's watching yeah
and what brilliant brother fujitsu said
was right he'd done a video of giving
you guys a reminder
that obviously for those muslims maybe
the non-muslims are watching as well
that when you break
your widow i mean when you uh break a
buddha you have to repeat this salah
um so that was it and it was a good
reminder it was good coming
slowly back to islamic reminder and this
god is doing it subtly what's wrong with
that
there is nothing wrong with that
brothers and sisters um and i wanted to
do this video
because of that so guys please please
for the sake of allah i'm just asking
you guys
let's have rahma mercy allah won't have
mercy on people that don't have mercy on
others
be gentle if you are a person of
knowledge
you should be more gentle the knowledge
that enters your heart if he's making
you more harsh if he's making you more
arrogant more stubborn more
self-righteous
you really need to question is this
knowledge entering the heart or is it
just um like a robot
algorithms that you're memorizing in
your head this is very important brother
and sisters for us to understand respect
that
make dua for brother fousey for him to
carry on
doing the worst works he's doing
inshallah at the beginning of the video
there was a link i'm raising
by the way uh funds for food in somalia
uh for people who are obviously in
desperation so please if you can give to
that i will really appreciate is that is
one inshallah we can hit two birds with
one stone
and give a reminder and get involved in
sadaka and zakah
and just bear in mind guys i'm a
youtuber yeah sometimes negative
comments gets you more than the positive
ones it's just how it was
psychologically built yeah okay
so please just understand that your
words your comments have an impact on
the individual
if you are a toxic person who wants bad
for him you're going to make any excuse
to attack him
if you're someone who genuinely cares
about his mental mental well-being
spiritual
well-being please guys give him message
of support
and show him that as his brothers and
sisters in his religion we love him for
the sake of allah is our brother
and alhamdulillah and to keep it like
that so yes that was it promises i hope
you guys enjoyed this video inshallah
don't forget to share it with your
friends and family
and maybe send us a fuzzy i hope you
didn't saw the see the thumbnail before
you know i'm having a go at him
i'm not genuinely i just wanted uh to
get this message across
uh because the reason i did a click bait
in that context is because i want his
haters to see you thinking i'm having a
good i'm like yeah but
i have a guy and we refuted them instead
of refuting brother fuzzy until next
time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi